we break and make love and then come
back we don't have now we need to do all
of those things but we should break and
then come back we got a lot of stuff
going on today Colin Quinn is sticking
around I'm not sticking around the whole
time I got business what do you do I got
all the radios are you gonna be here
after the break right oh yeah well see
we got Donald Sutherland Billy Bob
Thornton both of them are coming in
today Colin yep
are you gonna do a sling blade did you
hear that Hank for come what hey we got
a monkey jokes we gonna tell he's gonna
go crazy
hey no way somebody a [ __ ] blade yeah
hey what is [ __ ] [ __ ] what is ah
what are you gonna have someone can't
apatit me to [ __ ] and I can do my
Donald so the wind impression you know
he talks like this like really quiet hey
as a Caza blade I was like what's the
Kazin blade you're gonna eat a sandwich
on [ __ ] yeah we should you'll be [ __ ]
whether you're gonna be the guy from JFK
I'll just go man man we ought to be
[ __ ] team before what are you gonna
say that again what was Donald subtle
I'm gonna say go ahead I'd say I'm a
deep throat but don't take that the
wrong way meat and [ __ ] the can be the
big [ __ ] fat lady ain't mean Roland
they're going on a date
[Music]
stick my pecker like the fat boy
ship blade will be a popular film I dig
it